yeah good morning we are at the scene of
this major incident declared by the
Emergency Services uh here near
Bridgewater we're just at the edge of
the police Cordon here and further down
this road is where a double decker bus
which was being operated by Hinckley
Point C which of course is the huge
construction site around 10 miles north
of here at the nuclear power station and
it was carrying we understand around 70
workers we're not sure whether they were
going to or from the site these double
decker buses run 24 hours a day it is of
course Europe's biggest construction
site it was carrying workers when it was
involved in a crash which involved that
bus and a motorcyclist now this road of
course has been closed we've had a
number of statements from the emergency
services in the last hour or so even in
Somerset police who are leading this uh
investigation say they were called at
around 6 a.m to the a39 quantop road
following this incident a significant
number of police fire and ambulance
units are on the scene now we're
obviously at the moment being held quite
far back and down at that wooded area
there is where the majority of the
emergency service vehicles are just a
couple of moments ago an air ambulance
took off from the field beside me and
behind us here actually is a shell
garage which has become a bit of a a
base for the Emergency Services
we've had a statement from the fire and
rescue Service as well this morning who
said that they were called at 608 to
this incident as I say 70 people are on
board now we don't at the moment have a
number on the injuries
um as it stands so we're still waiting
for that from the ambulance service but
the fire service confirming that this
was declared a major incident and a
multi-agency incident between the fire
ambulance and police so that is the
information that we have at the moment
that has as well been a very brief
statement from Hinckley at Point C who
as I say
we found out this morning they have been
operating these buses they set a bus
carrying members of Hinckley poincy
Workforce were involved in this traffic
accident emergency services are on the
scene they have suspended travel too and
from the site we are expecting a
multi-agency response uh perhaps in the
next half an hour or so an update
perhaps on the number of people involved
and injured but clearly a significant
accident in what is a morning that has
seen many accidents up and down the
country with very icy conditions it is
around freezing here we don't know the
cause of it we know it involved a
motorcyclist and this major incident
continues